1. Santa Claus comes from the Dutch
sinter class which literally translates
as Saint Nicholas before Saint Nicholas
was even born though the Norse god Odin
was believed to lead a Hunting Party
through the sky during your and he even
delivered presents to Children two
mistletoe the latter half of mistletoe
evolved out of tan meaning TWIC the
missile part was another word for dung
kissing under the bird poo twig doesn't
really sound as romantic does it 3. the
word Nativity comes from the Latin word
nativus meaning born it's thought the
first nativity scene was created by
Saint Francis of Assisi in 1223 4.
mulled wine created by the Romans when
they'd heat wine to defend their bodies
against the cold winter its popularity
continued throughout the Middle Ages as
we mixed heated wine with spices
believing it would promote health and
prevent sickness and what better drink
to sit back and toast to this world of
culture and history we've surrounded
ourselves with merry Christmas one and
all